hello
i'm charlie engelke and i work in
developer relations for google cloud
platform
my focus is on serverless computing and
today's talk
we're going to see how you can run
almost anything serverlessly
using google cloud platform this is
important to me
because i was a software developer for
many years outside of google
and i always wanted to make the path
from it running on my machine to its
live on the web as short and simple as
possible
and that's what serverless computing
does it lets the developer's path be as
short as possible
from when your application is working as
far as you as a developer are concerned
until it's working as far as your
customers are concerned
serverless computing has a life cycle
that
to really break it down to its simplest
possible terms is
the developer builds the app tests the
app make sure it's all working
in the local environment and then the
platform takes over and does everything
else
it provisions computing and storage
resources it handles logging
monitoring health checks patching
hardware problems
all that stuff is the responsibility of
the platform
and as a developer in the past that's
what i really wanted to do i wanted to
focus on my application
not on the platform so serverless
computing
is great but it does have a deal you've
got to make as a developer
if you want to use a serverless
computing platform the platform offers
you this bargain
i'll provide you specific runtimes that
is to say environments for your app
and if you want to use me you're going
to have to fit into one of those
runtimes
that's not terribly restrictive a google
cloud platform has several
serverless platforms with a lot of
runtimes for instance there's app engine
which has been around for about a dozen
years and it supports
half a dozen different languages python
java node
php go and ruby is currently in beta
if instead of a web application you're
looking to deploy a web service
cloud functions is a platform for that
and it has
four runtimes of offers at the moment
python node
go and java is currently in beta
so if you've got an application in any
of those very common popular
environments
you're set you can use one of these
platforms as it is today
but what if you don't have your
application fit into one of those
runtimes
for example what if your application
needs to run a binary it's not just one
piece of source code
it's several different components that
run as binary code maybe they're in
other languages
maybe you've lost a source code or
you've licensed third-party code
or they may incorporate shell scripts
there's a whole lot of things
that might make you not fit into here
for example you may have
started working in a brand new language
and it's a perfect fit for what you need
in your application
but you can't find a platform that
supports it well in today's talk we're
going to talk about how to solve that
problem but we're going to give it
a problem that's the exact opposite
instead of two newer language
what happens if you need to run a 45
year old pascal
program to remind all of you who
may not remember or may not have been
around pascal was
the most popular computing language for
teaching in the 70s and 80s
and it was pretty well defined in this
little slim book
the pascal user manual report written by
jensen and worth
it was published in 1974 which is a full
third of a century before any of our
modern
serverless platforms existed so it's not
terribly surprising that the examples
weren't
optimized to work on serverless
computing but it does have a program in
it that we just have to make available
online
i found this program and i want
everybody to be able to get the benefit
of it
this is it it's a pascal program to
convert numbers to roman numerals
it may seem fairly simple but this has
been around for 45 years
any bugs in it presumably have been well
knocked out you enter a number and it
gives you back the roman numeral
now in order to do this first thing i
had to do was look and see
what serverless platforms will run my
pascal software as is and i could not
find any
but i still want one because i don't
want to manage my own environment i
don't want to run my own servers
i don't want to package my software and
deliver it as code that people run on
their own infrastructure
i want to take my application that is
working fine on my local machine
and make it available to anybody that's
got a web connection
cloud run lets me do that cloud run is
google's serverless platform
that offers a slightly different bargain
than the traditional one the traditional
bargain is
i'll give you a language environment you
fit into that environment you can run
serverlessly
cloud runs bargain is instead of just
bringing your source code
you have to bring a container now when
you first hear that you might think that
is a lot of extra complexity
instead of just bringing my own source
code you've probably
worked some with docker or seen about it
or used kubernetes
and you know that containers are
extremely flexible but there's a lot of
things you can do with it and a lot of
things you need to learn how to manage
cloud run is actually a very simple host
environment
for a container and it can be very easy
using tools on google cloud platform
in order to get this out and running and
that's what we're going to see
the easiest way to take our pascal
program
package it into container and let cloud
run manage it for us
containers can be a lot easier than you
might think easier than i thought
the first thing is you don't need to
install any of the traditional container
tools
you don't need to install docker because
cloud build
a google service can actually take your
specification
and your source code and build the
container that you need
for you on google's own infrastructure
not yours
not only that you don't have to figure
out how to build and specify this
container from scratch there are a lot
of quick start examples that are close
to what you need
and that's what we're going to do we're
going to take one of those and squeeze
in our pascal program with minor changes
changes don't require container
expertise and don't require container
software on your own machine
we're going to start with the cloud run
python quick start
that's at cloud.google.com slash run
slash docs slash quick starts slash
build
dash end dash deploy if you go to that
page
you'll see that there are only two files
in this example one is a very simple
python web application using the flask
framework
that just says hello world somebody
asked for the home page it says hello
world
that's it the other part of the quick
start is a docker file
that is a specification for how to
create the container which is to say
the run time that that python app
requires
we don't have to change a lot to make
this work with our pascal code
we're going to add the pascal source
code to the overall example so instead
of two files we're going to have three
we are going to make the docker file
compile it into a binary because we
can't
launch the pascal program and source
code we've got to convert it to an
executable
and then we're going to tweak the python
program so we're going to keep the
python program
but instead of it just saying hello
world that program is going to invoke
our pascal executable
let's see how that all is going to work
and why it's going to work that way
the starting point remember is that
pascal program
written in 1974. now cloud runs bargain
is
give me a container but the container is
supposed to handle web requests
cloud run will take incoming web
requests send them to your container
wait for the response and send it back
that's really all it expects your
container to do is handle web requests
this code doesn't do that that's because
this code was old enough to drive
before the web was invented this code
was written in 1974
tim berners-lee told the world about the
web in around 1990.
so not surprising that 1974 software
doesn't handle web requests
instead it handles requests from
standard input and it sends the answers
out to standard output
we're going to keep it that way and
we're going to let the rest of our
runtime environment
handle that for us first of all
let's take a look at the docker file the
docker file in the example is simple
it's only six lines long
and to deal with our pascal example we
only need to add three more lines to it
so the docker file is not terribly
intimidating let's take a look at what
every one of these lines does
and why we need it the first line says
what runtime we start with
we're given a container that can do a
lot of what we need and we just need to
add to it
in this case the container is a python
container that can run
python programs the last line of this
says
when cloud run invokes us what what
software inside the container does it
execute
well what it's going to do is it's going
to execute the g unicorn web server
using our pascal flask program
now in the middle we have to specify the
working directory
where all the software is expected to be
we set that up to be slash app
that is slash app in the containers file
system
not on our own local machine and we copy
all the software in our current working
directory when we build the container
into the container at that location so
that's how our pascal program gets into
the container
that's also how the python program gets
in there
but again the problem is the pascal
program source is in the container
we need the executable so the next three
lines
install software to do that we're using
the standard debian
package installer and the first line is
to update it so that when we
install we get the latest versions then
we install
fpc which is the free pascal compiler
that's available and it will actually do
the job we need in the next line which
is to compile our roman.pass
source code into an executable by
default the output of that compilation
step with the free pascal compiler
will be a file called roman our working
directory is slash app
so we're now going to end up inside the
container with slash app slash roman
as a binary executable all these run
steps by the way are happening
while the container's being built once
we have a container they'll all be
finished and they'll be ready to go
and then the final run step we have in
here is installing the necessary python
prerequisites
we're running an application that uses
the flask framework so we have to
install flask
and it's running under the g-unicorn web
server so we have to use a python
package installer
to install that as well when the
container is built
all this stuff will be executed and run
and we'll be ready to go ahead and have
the web server run our code
well our code as we say here is going to
be the python app
launched under the g unicorn web server
so let's take a look at that python app
the starting point in the quick start is
a simple hello world
and the flash framework basically says
here
is a path that might come in for a
request and here's the code you run
to respond to it so we have here app dot
route
slash the home page path just plain
slash
will run the hello world method and all
that method does is it checks to see if
there's an environment variable that
say hello to that instead of hello world
uh by default it then falls back to
using hello world
and then it returns that string hello
world that's it
very straightforward very simple what we
need to do
is modify this so that actually takes a
number
and figures out the roman numerals for
the number and sends the result back
so first of all how are we going to get
the number in there well the easiest way
i know of
is for somebody using their web browser
to put it in the url so instead of
requesting the web page at slash
request the pages some number
in flask you can specify that as a
placeholder and then say when you run
the hello world method pass it that
number which will be
bytes we convert that to a string and
now we have
something that we're ready to ask the
pascal program to parse
and manage so the next step is to run
the pascal program
using the linux sub process module we
tell it to run
our executable which again is it slash
app slash roman
we tell it for standard input send it
that string that we got the number
to be converted and to capture the
standard output
which will be our roman numerals and
then the final step is instead of
returning hello world
we're going to return the standard
output from when we ran the pascal
program
that's it not a lot of complicated
changes
let's go ahead and take a look at how to
do this with cloud run
we're going to have to start by building
the container so let's go over to a demo
where we get it started
because that can take a few minutes
because installing that free pascal
compiler
has a lot of prerequisites after we run
this command
we're going to come back here talk about
how the command worked and what we need
to do next to actually get it to run
we've created all the pieces of our
application and now we want to have it
running on
the cloud run platform in order to do
this we've got to create a container and
we've got to then send
the container to the cloud run service
that can all be done
from the command line on your local
machine but i'm going to actually do it
without anything installed locally
and in order to do this i'm going to the
google cloud console
at console.cloud.google.com this
site is where you can create a new
google cloud platform project
and everything you do is going to be in
the context of a project so we have to
create one
and your project is going to be a name
you give it my case angle key next
and it'll create a systemwide project id
which
in many cases can be the exact same
thing if the name you picked is globally
unique
i'm going to build it still with the
command line tools and in order to do
that instead of running them on my local
machine
i'm going to activate cloud shell cloud
shell comes
with the cloud console any web web
browser can let you connect to it any
modern web browser
whether you're on windows mac linux a
chromebook
you name it once you connect to it it's
going to give you a pre-provisioned
linux instance and you can run the
commands there
let's take a look at what's already in
my instance i've been here before
so i've already got a directory with the
source code we've seen so far in it
there are a couple of ways you can get
that source code onto your
linux instance for cloud shell one is
you've got tools like
git already installed so you can get
something from a git repo
or you can use the commands over here in
a menu to upload files from your local
machine
there are variety ways to do it in this
case they're already there so let's take
a look at the files that we created
and go ahead and build the container
we want to build it in the google cloud
platform using the google build
cloud build service the command for that
is gcloud
builds with an s submit and then we give
it a tag so we can find it later in
order to deploy it that tag is going to
be in an artifact repository
in gcr.io in this case i've named it
based on
my project angle keynext and i've given
it a service name it could be pretty
much anything
since this is for roman numerals i
picked a service called roman
if this is the first time you use the
cloud build service
you may be prompted that it's got to be
activated
and it'll offer to do that for you it'll
add a couple of minutes to do the build
normally building a container can be
relatively quick
but in this case it's going to take
quite a while and that's because
we have this container installing
software including the free pascal's
compiler
that turns out to have an awful lot of
dependencies and it's going to take a
while to do that full build
so we're going to go ahead go back to
our talk and see what the commands
actually mean that we've just done and
we're going to see what other commands
we need to do
we'll come back here after this build is
finished
all right what we just did was use the
cloud shell
in the web console for google cloud
platform
to actually invoke a command that's
going to run cloud build
and build our container let's take a
look at all the pieces of the command
and what we asked it to do
the first part is the gcloud command
line tool we could run this locally on
our own machine but if we did we'd have
to install it
we'd also have to set up credentials on
our local machine saying that we are
authorized to actually build a container
using cloud build
if we do this all under the cloud shell
everything is set up for us ahead of
time
so we can run the gcloud command and we
want to run
cloud build the sub command for that is
builds build s
and what it's going to do is create a
container using the specification
in the environment we can specify it a
lot of different ways by default it's
going to look for a docker file in the
current directory
and use that after it's done we want it
to submit that container somewhere so
it's ready for us to pass on to cloud
run
we're going to submit it to an artifact
repository and tag it
with a name that is based on our current
project id
as you saw the project we were working
on was called engel key next
i used my name to make it globally
unique and then slash the name of a
service and we can use just about
anything for that service name
we used roman because this service is
going to give you roman numerals
once that's finished and we'll go back
in a minute to see that it's finished
and go on to the next step
once it's finished we're ready to then
ask cloudrun to go ahead and take that
container
and deploy it serverlessly and we use
the same gcloud
command line interface to do it but in
this case since we're talking to
the cloud run service the sub command is
run so it's going to be gcloud run
and then the action we want to perform
is to deploy it
we need to tell it what image to deploy
and it's in that same artifact
repository and we tell it how it was
tagged
and then we've got to tell it where to
deploy it because cloud run is available
on google cloud's platform fully managed
but it's also available
on an environment you manage either on
google cloud or
somewhere else like your own
infrastructure we've got to tell it
which of those to deploy
and as you saw from my talking about how
much i like serverless you know
i like to do the least and have the
platform do the most which means i want
to deploy it to the managed platform
and then the final thing we have to put
in here is something about who's allowed
to run this because by default
google cloud run will require all web
requests coming in to be authenticated
and will only actually pass them to your
cloud run container
if they're authenticated by somebody you
permit well this
particular service the roman numerals is
too valuable we can't hold it back from
the world
we want everybody to be able to do it
without any authentication so we include
the allow unauthenticated flag
let's go ahead back to the demo run this
command it doesn't take quite as long to
deploy it as it took to build it because
of that install step we had in the build
and then we'll see how it actually works
the container is finished building
we can see that it was a success and it
was pushed
so now we can go ahead and deploy it
with the gcloud run deploy command
again if it's the first time you've done
a cloud run deploy
you may be asked to activate some apis
and it'll do that for you
in this case that's already been done
but it's going to ask what i want to
call the service and it will infer from
the tag i gave it that i want to call it
roman
roman numerals that's a good name and
then where to deploy it i'll go ahead
and deploy it to the us central one
region
now i'm going to deploy the container
and this takes a few minutes because
it's not only going to deploy the
service
it's got to set up access control even
though we said allow unauthenticated
and it's got to set up traffic routing
so that everything gets to this cloud
container properly
once it's finished running we'll be able
to go take a look at
what the url is and actually invoke it
so
while this is still going ahead and
running let's go ahead and in the top
part of the console
go take a look at the cloud run part
and we can see this is being built it's
not finished yet
if we take a look at the details
we'll see it's still in progress
once it's finished this will show us the
url
right now it says it's loading and after
it finishes showing us the url we'll be
able to
invoke the service just by opening a
webpage that url
if we didn't tell it allow
unauthenticated we'd have to send an
authenticated request
one with a header that contains proof of
our identity
this is going to be a lot easier in this
case all right the revision deployment
is finished
it's been deployed it's serving 100 of
the traffic
and here's the url when we invoke the
url
we're going to be disappointed right at
first and that's because it comes back
with an error message
well that error message is not cloud
run's fault
our python wrapper program set told how
to handle
urls that had slash followed by a string
that we were going to interpret as a
number
this url does not have that string so we
didn't tell it how to handle it
so the python wrapper function just
doesn't know what to do with it and
returned an error
let's go ahead and tell it we want to
take a look at
the roman numeral for 1974.
and it comes back and gives us that
it's not in the shortcut for roman
numerals uh
when they wrote this program it was
easier to write it this way and clearer
for the purpose of teaching but also the
fact is in the earliest days
uh romans didn't tend to use the
shortcut versions anyway
let's try another number you may have
noticed when you look at my console that
i
am doing this recording on july 20th
that is the anniversary of the first
lunar landing on july 20th 1969.
so let's take a look at 1969 in roman
numerals
and again it converts it right away
anybody in the world that knows this url
can go ahead and do this conversion as
long as this is live
uh the next slide once i show up the
demo will actually have a url that i'm
going to be leaving live
for a few months if you want to try it
out yourself or of course you can deploy
your own
now this is not a very easy url to
memorize or give to other people
you can if you have your own domain
actually configure cloudrun
to respond with a page at one of the
urls on your own domain
we're not going to cover that here it's
fully documented in the web pages
okay as you saw it was pretty easy to
actually create the container
without having any local install and to
deploy it to cloud run and now it's
available on the internet for everybody
to access
that url that i did in the demo is for a
throwaway project it's not going to keep
running for very long
but i still have this available at this
url on this slide so you can come back
at any time
and you can go to that webpage because
you probably need to convert
numbers to roman numerals all the time
we're going to keep this application up
for the next several months not
promising it forever
now again this is not the world's
friendliest url to memorize
it is possible to actually use your own
domain
and have your own url pointing to the
service as well we're not going to cover
how to do that
but it's fully documented at the website
we have now seen that you can run almost
anything serverlessly
and you do that by creating container
and containers can be easy
with google cloud platform with cloud
run and cloud build to create them
you can do that without any local docker
install and if you use google cloud
shell you don't need to have anything
on your own machine except a web browser
which if you're watching this talk
we know you've got a web browser
available to you you can start with a
lot of docker file samples that are
close to what you need
so you don't have to learn how to create
docker file
specifications from scratch and in fact
it depending on what you need your
container to do you may not have to
have a docker file at all build packs
which are described at buildpacks.io
that website can eliminate the need for
a docker file entirely
they can actually look at your source
code structure and create the container
from that
i don't think you're going to find a
bill pack however that can handle pascal
but all said and done everything we did
here is something you're probably not
going to do
need to do exactly as given you're
probably not going to need to run pascal
software
on a serverless platform but it's a lot
more likely you may need to run
something in a language that's too new
to have
much support on source code oriented
serverless platforms
and in fact it's extremely likely that
your application is going to have many
components
that include pieces you've already got
in binary only form either because
they've been around
for your company for a while you've lost
the source code or
possibly you've licensed them in binary
form only
or you may have other old languages
unlike pascal it's a lot likely you may
need to run old fortran
or cobalt programs all of those are
things you can do
now because cloud run greatly expands
the universe of software that you can
run
serverlessly you can run
almost anything that's what we promised
but there are a couple of restrictions
we mentioned that your software is only
going to be run in order to process web
requests
cloud run's not going to invoke your
software unless it has a request for it
to respond to
and after it gets your response it's
going to stop your software from running
so you can't leave anything running all
the time in the background
the other restriction is your software
has got to be stateless
if you put something in your source code
that for example has a global variable
keeping account of how many times
you've received a web request well every
time a web request comes in it may be
going to a different container
and affecting a different global
variable it's not going to have any
meaning if you need to keep state
don't keep state in your container keep
state external to it
for instance in an external database so
i hope this has been useful
that you have seen that learning how to
run a 45 year old pascal program on a
modern serverless platform
can show you some other techniques that
actually are more applicable to your
general use
if you have any questions please use the
q a we'll be answering them
as quickly as we can get to them and
again
thank you very much for your attention